THE RULES COMMITTEE FOR AUGUST
TWENTY THIRD IS HEREBY CALL TO
ORDER.
POPPY FIELD BISON HUNTING THEM
CORNER TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS BEING
MADE HAS ALSO TELEVISED.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY.
CUNNINGHAM.
CARILLO.
AROUND HERE GALLAGHER.
HERE.
GRAYSON HERE KAMLAGER-DOVE MAYES
ALMOST YOUR NAZARIAN PRESIDENT
FALLEN SNOW THAT CHILDREN.
YOURSELF ONE I KNOW WE HAVE A
QUORUM.
NOW WE HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA.
AND MISTER VICE CHAIR YOU HAD A
NOSE CONCERNING.
SURE I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THROUGH.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AJ ARE YOU ONE
CONSENT [inaudible]
GOV MAYES I MAYES I KNOW VERY.
NAZARIAN AYE SALAS I SALAS AYE
WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
SHARE MOTIONS PASSED IS OUR
MOTION OUT OF SEVEN SO --
BY.
MR DESERVE A SECOND I'M IS
CARILLO --
MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
COOLEY AYE AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO CARILLO AYE
CARILLO AYE CERVANTES AYE
CERVANTES AYE GALLAGHER NO
GALLAGHER NO GRAYSON.
GRAYSON I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
MAYES.
MAYES KNOWN AS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE SALAS AYE SALAS AYE
WALDRON.
WALDRON NOW MOTION --
FOR THAT MOTION PASS AND JUST
AND PROCEDURES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH